des automates accessible en dehors des
horaires d'ouverture et une vingtaine de
salariés pour accueillir la clientèle
depuis le 9 juillet dernier le bureau de
poste de saint quentin en yvelines a
investi ses nouveaux locaux ça fait
quelques temps qu'on cherchait des
locaux pour moderniser l'ancien bureau
or on est sur une surface de 510 mètres
carrés donc c'est assez dur à trouver
et on a eu l'opportunité avec les deux
boutiques étaient ici de récupérer les
locaux et donc de venir s'implanter au
plus près sans s'éloigner néanmoins de
la garde
le site propose les mêmes services que
le précédent bureau qui accueillait 1000
clients par jour
elle les nouveaux locaux sont au sein
même de l'espace saint quentin mais
c'est beaucoup plus écrire et c'est plus
pratique pour nous en plus si on veut
faire quelques commissions à côté c'est
très pratique il était déjà pas très
loin de chez moi
quand ils étaient près de la gare donc
ça change pas grand chose pour moi mais
je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
moderne et puis celui du centre
commercial donc ça très bien devant les
anciens locaux situés à deux pas de la
gare la boîte aux lettres a laissé place
aux palissades de chantier
le bâtiment est voué à la destruction le
futur édifice sera occupé par
l'opérateur orange